fue directamente del asado smoc
mordisqueando en el aeropuerto de kabul
mil personas sanas han estado y esperando
por a y nuez de los talibanes tom oil decker
controlar afganistán con esperanza
ser d'acqua dos la multi tutti
rodea y el aeropuerto ha complicado la
súper acción
tarjetas de sal puccio vi unser evacuado
sucio se irá con el esfuerzo
Americano o social ados no puliero
ex y fue el aeropuerto
algunos suelo ser basura aaron otros y
fundas fueron maxi ios
le pregunto a hiroto city o esa no es kim para
toda la samba d'asio piscinas lejos
entonces que
fue nido suni dosificado que organiza
la seva problemas con la juve detras
los espías y los disparos son raros en el proceso
cerca de dos ddos ​​senaldi susan lee ad
anna sept erosivo cuando se levantan
temporalmente mientras se unen informantes
diciendo que el smi ambrose de los talibanes
ambus cadeau incluido por persona
salas a quien acusa de ayudar es lo
estado unidos los ados sociales alrededor
de seismi el soldado si nos stan
y en el suelo ayudando y super accion
si en el aeropuerto
joe biden si me comprometo doy para evacuar
a todos sudavano si americano
restante
no no no se chivu che mose questo
misión de evacuación de la liga rosa spe
la física tiene éxito spa nuestros oscuros propósitos
ambas llaves retroceden
circunstancias dificiles dessena 2000 y es
la persona viene con la esperanza de poder escalar
afganistán cazador del 31 de agosto la
limit scum para lo retira de completo
delta dos unidos del pais al frente
de los multi todos los gunhus saben que
diesel habiendo ayudado a lascorz de la o
time o de estados unidos a las etiquetas en el
documento y esperando que
ciudad americana y ne yo